Pictorially, the Kalman
filter looks like this.
Nice Gaussian.
I don't know why I'm drawing this.
It's already here.
A Gaussian, I'll circle it.
We start off with that Gaussian.
We then have the linear prediction part,
which does the shift.
We then say, but wait a minute,
there may be some noise,
so things get widened.
We take our measurement,
and we sort of blend.
Remember, it was that the Kalman
filter is a, a blending between your
prediction, which was what our,
our prediction here was.
And your measurement, and it creates
a new estimate that's a weighted average
between those, depending upon
the relative uncertainties, and
the uncertainty gets smaller
after we take the measurements.
So uncertainty gets bigger
when we do our prediction,
because we don't know
exactly what happened,
and it gets smaller again
when we take the measurement.
We said nice things about it was
that it's simple, it's compact,
it's efficient and
it's very easy to spell.
The cons of it are in fact,
maybe I should have listed
these in the other order.
Here it says, we'll say there's sort of
a restricted class of motions defined by
the linear model.
Linear thing we can get around by using
what's called an extended Kalman filter.
A much bigger problem is, it's nice,
it's got this nice unimodel
distribution assumption.
You're assuming the world really is
a nice Gaussian of some uncertainty.
And the question arises, what would you
do, if it, things are not a Gaussian?
So what's an example of when you
might need a non-Gaussian situation?
Well you remember these videos?
Okay, and
again this comes from the Isard and
Blake condensation tracking paper.
There's all sorts of dynamics going
on here with things jumping around.
Let's see if I do that again,
yeah there she goes.
And things move quickly, they they may
be able to be nice and smooth sometimes,
then something rapid will happen.
So like when the leaves are blowing in
the wind for a while they blow nicely.
But basically, the problem here is
that things are moving smoothly and
then all of a sudden you'll
get a perturbation, and
you'd like to be able
to keep track of that.
So graphically we're going to
show that like this, okay.
So now we have the same model
that we had before, okay?
We have a,
an estimate from the last time.
We have a deterministic shift.
We apply some smoothing because
we grow the uncertainty.
And then we take our measurement and
we update our estimate.
But now these are not
Gaussian lumps all right.
These are sort of arbitrary
distributions, and
in fact this particular figure is
taken from the paper that introduced
the particle filtering that we'll talk
about in a minute, to computer vision,
that, that condensation paper,
I just mentioned.